everybody's gary vay-ner-chuk and this
is episode 309 of the askgaryvee show
and i'm excited to have a wonderful
entrepreneur to take your questions so
Instagram and Facebook start throwing in
your phone numbers with maybe a hashtag
or two or data point of like where your
question is going to get raghav some
indicator but obviously as we get into
this episode more data will be thrown
out and so you can add on that
continuously put your numbers in there
and we will pick some for the call but
this young lady has built a very
impressive resume we met on The Today
Show doing some entrepreneurial stuff
and I will Ally say hello so for the
vaynernation why don't you tell
everybody who you are and what you do so
my name is Ali Wehbe and I founded a
company called Drybar I feel like
there's a lot of men in this room but
for all the ladies out there we are a
blow job are really actually it's only
four to three
this is actually the best ratio I think
we normally I'm pretty I'm pretty pub
with the 4 to 3 ratio so yeah we were
the first we started 10 years ago we
have 125 locations across the country
4,000 style and when did you start 2010
and when you say you were the first
because I'm very aware of the movement
maybe just right so there was nothing
like it when I started nothing nothing
and what and so - back to that and I
think by the way real quick for all the
entrepreneurs there one of the biggest
questions I get is what you know people
take so much emotion in inventing
something we're adding on to something a
little bit differently and then when
there's something successful there's
fast followers and they get so upset
about that and I'm like look that's just
market dynamics just because I'm just
excited yeah I mean listen I I feel like
you know to unpack that a little you
know but we didn't invent blowouts we
created a much better experience around
it and the advice anyone all in yeah and
well and we just we just kind of changed
the game and they the advice I give
entrepreneurs is like there may be
something out there that exists that you
love you just wish was done better and
we created a much better experience and
price point and location around blowouts
that just did not exist you used to have
to go to a full-service salon or a desk
chain
and you know the experience just wasn't
great was overpaying am I wrong in this
wasn't it just one of the menu items
versa it was a menu item and it was also
one that most stylists didn't want to do
because they wanted to use that hour to
do a haircut that you could charge a lot
more from they didn't want to do a
blowout which was less money and it's
funny because it really harkens back to
the day of like our grandmothers and
grandmother's generation where they'd
get their hair coughed and they wouldn't
touch it for like a week we kind of
modernized that behavior but no make no
mistake I did not know none of us knew
my brother Michael and as my business
partner also bald like none of us knew
that we what we were like what was in
front of us we didn't realize how big
this opportunity was I was gonna open
one store in LA pick up my kids from
preschool and that was gonna be my
little life and then you know the fact
that like the market respond be so
underestimated the demand let me give
you a comp and then we'll go back to the
origin story for a while now about 20
months it's been running through my head
that like a french fries only restaurant
USR would dominate right you didn't
invent french fries oh man it was a side
dish you get like all different flavors
of French yeah I've really hot on the
whole concept but like the different
ketchups and mustards and salts but one
core french fries so it's not like seven
different french fries and my concept is
this crazy french fry that everyone's
about but it's the other things like the
11 different ketchups the 11 different
Mayo is the 11 different mustards and
like the 13 different salts are so bad
for you yeah but but they're my weakness
no but there maybe we have a healthy
sixth person is getting brain cancer
from self fitness I don't need to hear
people's like like if that was like the
last thing I could eat it would be
french fries I love french fries so much
so I'm I am all-in on this furnace we've
already won being you do it well that's
my concept that's right so you started
dry bar it's 125 locations yes franchise
model or all yours they're predominantly
company owned I'd say we're about 40
give or take franchise and the rest
company owned which you know good I
could make the argument either way that
it's there my great great things about
franchising and there's not great things
about franchising and you know again I
could make look the pyramid
reason you can make an argument is now
here we are 75 years later and both
independently owned corporate entities
and franchise models both have a place
at the table they really do they really
do in question is the mix of the two
yeah there's a fast thing and it's
challenging because you know you have
it's a whole business finding and
running a franchise organization and
there's a lot there's just a different
set of problems you know issues so but
yeah I I think I think both are great
and we've we've got momentum in the
company now like it's a product is a big
is a big push I mean we have almost over
3,000 points of distribution we're in
Nordstrom Ulta Sephora were
international with products we have a
massive product line from tools to dry
shampoos to shampoos like you know you
name it and what's great is if you don't
have access to dry bar but you know and
love dry bar which luckily most women
know about now you can buy the products
and do kind of replicate what we're
doing in the shop let's take this way
way back what kind of girl were you
growing up were you entrepreneurial were
you like sporty well even as my parents
they would have been like they would
have told you I was such the
underachiever my brother Michael who I
mentioned total overachiever Michael P
Keating which I know you get that
reference I don't know what do you know
oh god we tired horse Mike J box
yes which I'm sure a lot of people
listening don't know that reference but
he was like the overachiever of the
family and you know I was just
I've always been where Malory yeah I was
like I don't totally remember her I
remember her but not her character but I
was just kind of like it'll all work out
and I was never really worried about
things we grew up South Florida and my
hair is naturally curly so in South
Florida it was very frizzy and I was
always trying to figure out how to get
it straight and I used to beg my mom to
blow out my hair and that theme of hair
and trying to figure out my hair kind of
was always there and I think I feel like
the seed was planted to do something in
hair when I was kid but then you know as
I grew up and went to high school in
college and well I didn't really go to
college I went for like a minute and I
just you know all my friends knew what
they were gonna major in and I really
didn't know and I was so lost and
confused out of high school and I went
to college for a second like a semester
was supposed to I maybe went first right
but here I went to like class all that
much cuz I was like what
I don't they're not interested in
anything this is my high school report
card this is Micah high school report
card yeah I mean we're about we're about
the same yeah yeah just notice that
there's a small engine here's the
greatest thing about one of my favorite
things about my life is that I get asked
to speak at colleges all the time and
every time they ask me I'm like you know
I didn't actually graduate from college
I just want to be upfront with that but
that just goes to show you that I mean
not that I'm against college I mean go
to college get an education however you
can but my parents were entrepreneurs so
I grew up in an entrepreneurial
environment so so then I didn't even
know I was getting that education frown
on so no bills my parents sing go to
college either but a lot of parents go
the other way yeah right so but my
parents were so it's pretty
congressional and they were like we just
want you to do what makes you happy they
weren't so thrilled when I made the
decision to go to beauty school because
I think things that what happened next
so I went no I went to like went
technically to Florida State I just
didn't go to class very often I grew up
in Florida yep and then I was like this
is not for me I moved home and then I
moved to New York City I thought I
wanted to work in fashion and I worked
for like Nicole Miller and Cynthia
Rowley this was like 25 years ago and
then my brother and I started Nicole
Miller licensed stores in Boca which is
where we grew up
I realize didn't want to do that and
Michael and I were fighting so much I
was like what the hell am I going to do
with my life and I was like you know the
only thing that I'm really passionate
about is hair and I want to learn how to
do hair and I had worked at a hair salon
in high school where they would blow out
my hair and it was so magical to me and
so I said I think I should go to beauty
school my brother by the way was like
you should go I can see you doing
editorial and fashion shows in New York
and I had this grand vision of what I
would do with hair where my parents
stores were like little old lady
clothing stores and like retirement
communities in South Florida and they
were like you want to go work at beauty
parlours and I was like no I want to do
something amazing in hair and of course
I didn't have the vision of Drybar back
then but I took the plunge went to
beauty school again my parents my
parents dismay and how did that go they
you know they supported it and paid for
it I feel like my mom was paying off
those loans forever from beauty school
because beauty school wasn't cheap
either and
and but but I like that literally the
day I walked in I was like this is where
I was meant to really I loved it I fell
in love with it I wanted to learn
everything I could learn if it said the
only thing I was ever really passionate
about which get it again it's such a
good example for people out there who
are like they feel like maybe the thing
that they they're passionate about isn't
like a great career option you know it's
my singular thesis yeah I I really
believe somebody watching right now who
loves you know Star Trek or Black
Panther or whatever I really genuinely
or making homemade jam
I believe it yeah and I believe it
because of the Internet I didn't believe
it in 1963 because there wasn't a system
to go into yeah like you can start a
Black Panther Instagram account and a
podcast and be active on Black Panther
forums and Facebook groups and overtime
attraction attraction and something
could happen yeah that wasn't real so
living in the day we're like anything
can happen I mean anybody can make it
doing all sorts of stuff and and I think
that I'm a great example choice but I
think making it is the biggest
conversation that entrepreneurs like you
and I who've made it
need to start helping the next
generation because making it I believe
if you love Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
and you make a hundred thousand a year
because you have for sponsors
Nickelodeon you know the the convention
who knows right and you make a hundred
thousand a year hosting a TMT TMNT
teenager like podcast and an Instagram
account is a much better life than
making two thirteen as an executive at
McKinsey and being grossly unhappy and
taking right because I mean the term
making it is so relative no no and and
I'm so glad you're jumping on this it is
probably I believe that went with with
anything that works out for you there's
I don't think it's a sense of
responsibility but I like giving back to
the game that put me on so I love
entrepreneurship so much that like so
much of who I am and what I'm about is
to give back to the system yeah but you
have to update the system and we have to
update what being successful looks like
it has to be happy you're not rich it
has to be yeah well I mean I couldn't
agree with that more I mean money is
like was not the driver ever for me I
mean my
was like gravy you know is like oh this
oh we're gonna actually like make a
living doing this amazing but it was
never about money and you know we didn't
we didn't pay ourselves for years you
know when we first started drybrough it
was never about money it's never been
about money and even he's already family
when you started yes I had my I have two
sons and they were three and five when I
started they're 11 and 14 now let's talk
about that for five seconds okay I
really want this is a subject matter
that I've been wanting to get more into
okay well it's a particularly
interesting subject matter beep for me
because I'm going through a divorce but
that's public but um so let's put that
on the side for a second so it's been a
quite up here for me I respect that and
I'm sorry to hear that but what if you
can indulge me yes I think one of the
other things that I like to do is talk
about what I know and I like to talk
about things I've lived through I will
never have the luxury of being an
entrepreneurial mom no and I think it's
never gonna happen that's right that is
not in the best do you have kids though
I do ok out of your heads
eleven nine and six about sure yeah just
of both very close to eleven and seven
nine it's almost a letter and you know
and I think people have diff I hate when
people think they understand something
that they'll never be I love when people
like I get you I'm like no no you'll
never be an immigrant too like I get you
you know you're never gonna be a woman
or an african-american or all right
great or Muslim during this time like
you could be sympathetic you can be
empathetic but you'll never fully know
so I want to take advantage of this
because I have a humongous audience I
spend a lot of time engaging with mother
entrepreneurs but I never go all the way
with my advice because I don't want to
give advice that isn't predicated on
things that I've tasted I have thoughts
thoughts and thesis as we all do sure
but I want to take advantage of this yep
how much if any this is right off the
top a core question I'd love to hear
your perspective on how much if any
guilt did you feel tons always this is
something I don't believe a father will
ever feel anywhere in the same world as
a mother sorry I don't think so can I
curse you can find a lot I don't think
it's [ __ ] up like this because it
because it's going I all the time and
I'm I speak all the time and people
always ask that question to women like
why why don't you feel guilty as a
father when you don't get to be home
with your kids as much as you could
because you're propaganda that we were
fed that's what I mean that's what I
mean that's what I think I'm curious
about this I'm curious about the process
of giving birth right so adding else I
will never feel that is not funny I'm
making an assumption it hurt oh I have
no idea that there is some sort of
connection point that is fundamentally
different when a humans in [ __ ] inside
of you
and then as a human versus it was never
inside of him and like look I think
listen I know the way I feel about my
mom versus the way I feel about my dad I
love them endlessly both there's some
crazy [ __ ] real [ __ ] going on there
with mom that's just [ __ ] real it's
true it was here I was inside apart yeah
look I I mean I would be there for nine
months I will be my home
I would make that same joke to my
ex-husband and say like you know they're
more mine than yours because they
literally came out of my body genuinely
actually believe even like that but
forget about should guys or not guys
feel guilt back to the point yeah I it
hurts my soul cuz entrepreneurship is
hard enough mm-hmm it is so difficult it
is outrageously lonely yeah it is
outrageous you have to have a thick skin
for it no doubt oh and especially if
you're a mom I mean luckily my mom
actually passed away three years ago but
she was there for the beginning of
Drybar and she and when I had my life
got so turned upside down in an amazing
way and I had to travel all the time and
it's so much great opportunities coming
at me and there was so much momentum and
excitement with Drybar and I had
traveled tons and luckily my mom was
there so she was with my kids all the
time because and the guilt was massive
but had I had to leave her with a nanny
my kids with a nanny that would have
been double mess oh god I don't even
know if I could have done it because my
kids were so young and you know that my
mom was there it was like you know
someone who's like his family and loved
them and so I felt very lucky in that
regard but you know listen that's not to
say I didn't feel like the world is so
polarizing right now that's not to say
if you have a nanny and you're an
entrepreneur that's not okay to you
appreciate that that's okay to whatever
works for you look
and that's by the way why I don't feel
like like look some people like Gary
like inevitably based to your point
polarizing and everybody being so
hardcore Gary you should feel guilt no I
shouldn't you don't know me like yeah
what about guys who whose mother has
brain cancer when they start their
business do you feel bad for them now
yeah my biggest thing is you know
nothing about people yeah like my energy
I know it's going through somebody you
can't imagine how different any news now
I'm going through a divorce
ten years ago I not that I had any
judgment on that it's funny than my
brain would think about it for a second
be like what is it I have become numb
because of how polarizing the world is
yeah my hope is this is what's actually
gonna happen to everybody else because
my life has been predicated on doing
actions a little bit earlier than others
and then figuring it out yeah the level
of judgment I have on anybody at this
point is almost non-existent same I
don't know what's going on I know what's
going on and I wore a certain point
right he may share something with you
Jason shared some stuff on families I
got some context I got a little
something you don't know what's going on
with your spouse you don't know what's
going on with your children you don't
know what's going on with your parents
all the way yeah nobody knows anybody
else all the way it's so true I mean I
feel like my mom always said like like
this I mean nobody relates like if you
have nothing nice to say say nothing and
I feel like yeah you know it's like you
just don't know and I've said I've
always felt it like you just don't know
what someone else is going through it
any given moment say you're right I
could not agree with that statement or
all will go through judgment moments
yeah whether it's a divorce just keep
them to yourself what well but that's
you know you know that that's you're
gonna live you're living it through your
most inner circle and as it gets more
public yeah people are judgment that are
watching that Facebook has never heard
of you
yeah but only people are watching yeah
have never heard of I know I thanked
them was heard you say it's seven
minutes and minutes ago and whether they
typed it or thought it yeah that's what
humans do and that's fine that's gnats
it's not like I don't have judgment hey
but I think much like we started eating
better much like we're now doing better
with our mental you know health and yeah
just started doing transcendental
meditation which is life-changing by the
way good for you and we'll go to that
and
we need to start we need to show
yourself help podcast re we need to
start an anti judgment process and
movement yeah I couldn't agree my first
name is AJ anti judgment I kind of like
this whole thing right now please put
your phone numbers in I want to get some
phone calls in what was the most
ridiculously fun exciting moment in the
early part when did what would you tell
me one story in 2010 you started in 2011
2012 give me some story of where you
were like holy [ __ ] honestly there so I
know I know and a great question which I
don't know really ever been asked that
and I'll tell you why I've asked it
because I lived it like I had so many
moments but if I was reversed right now
I'd probably say when Conan had me on
his show when I was doing my wine vlog
nobody from the internet was really on
TV yet besides Perez Hilton yeah and it
was like this huge moment where like my
brother came from college and we watched
it that was a moment where we like holy
[ __ ]
give me one holy [ __ ] moment like to
overcome in well somebody magazine you
know Carson Daly very much and he's had
he had a radio show for a long time so
does and this was promised was really I
think in 2010 like within a few months
of us starting which reminds me of Ryan
Seacrest had a show and Justin Bieber's
was talking about driver I mean there's
there's so many of those women but Ryan
Seacrest we were brand new maybe two or
three months and Carson Daly sorry
Carson Daly I started getting all these
phone calls and did you like to make
this story even better
did you love Carson Daly on TV okay oh
yes okay I knew it because if you're out
every day yeah cool people follow me on
Instagram and you're like holy [ __ ] yes
but if it's something I really gave a
[ __ ] about yeah they may be far less
famous like somebody may follow me
that's the most relevant Netflix star
right now and am i cool but but like WWF
wrestlers that I grew up like a Brutus
the barber beefcake followed me right
now I'd lose my [ __ ] so good but so
Carson Daly had had a show and and you
would have thought we paid him because
he went off he was must have he was on
his computer looking at our website
talking about all our looks he I think
he even said something like oh look at
Ali Wehbe who's this
girl or something like that and I was
like he just called me hot he's talking
yeah I know why this story that was the
easiest tale of all time I love you for
that is really the definitely the reason
if anybody ever calls me hot publicly at
scale it is the core thing I'm excited
about let's get very ActiveE called hi
hunter national radio if you love t-ara
like that exactly which by the way i
love him he's married and his wife comes
to drive are nothing like that nobody
think i also had something worse i
everything in seven years ago people are
it was ten years ago
I don't even if he was married then
anyways that was a big moment and then
very soon after that Ryan Seacrest on
the Ryan Seacrest show had Justin Bieber
on they literally called
Drybar la Justin was like hey it's
Justin Bieber I want to make an
appointment to come to dry bar and and
the girl on the phone god bless her she
was like I'm I'm sorry who and he was
like it's Justin Bieber and I'd like to
get the Bieber which is like what his
hair was a big thing remember when he
had the hair this again was like ten
years ago
and she was like I mean and she took it
very seriously and she thought she was
being like Punk'd because why would
Justin Bieber because I got the whole
thing on the show up news and and none
of those things I knew about people
started calling us and they're like you
know dry bars and then like Jimmy Kimmel
talks about us all the time but his wife
Molly who's now a friend it wasn't a
friend at the beginning she she's his
one of his writers and she would write
and she goes to drive her all the time
so she would write us into the Jimmy
Kimmel show and was the same thing I was
like Jimmy Kimmel is talking about us
unlike his Nate late-night show was a
single scariest day okay well asked nine
years what was the single singular
toughest day for you personally and it
might not have been like some death blow
to the company but for you personally
yeah like well I think so hard while a
while ago I remember it was still very
new maybe a year or two in we were
starting to do kind of promotions with
big companies and we were doing
something with HBO we do a lot of
partnerships now with big companies and
promoting like movies or TV shows that
because we have flat-screen TVs in our
shops that you can watch while you're
standing a blowout and we do a lot of
partnerships now but the very first one
we did was with HBO girls and we didn't
realize that they basically
I was giving away it was doing happy
hours so they were giving away free blow
outs to like the first you know I don't
know what it was like hundred people who
called and and it was just one happy
hour and we I think we had at the time
like maybe 20 stores and those people
who called first got free blowout we
promoted the [ __ ] out of this to our
entire audience which was like I don't
know a couple hundred thousand at that
point and we were giving out a couple of
hundred blow outs which was way more we
disappointed way more people than we
actually like delighted so it was such a
[ __ ] and we didn't realize it at the
time that we needed to kind of like
purse it out and not not tell everybody
they can win a blow first group was
pumped and then yeah many but what
happened as you know it like totally
backfired on us because so many more
people couldn't get in on I'm gonna go
[ __ ] your birthday and we were like [ __ ]
and they were right and people were
upset and I was getting I mean I was
getting so many like mean emails or we
did like categorize them and I had to
like make a statement to the press like
I'm so sorry like we did we messed up we
didn't realize we didn't do this right
which now we learned our lesson and
we're like no more careful and
methodical numbers were about to do
questions please you got one go ahead
that makes sense yeah it was crazy it
there's really but you want us to learn
more disappointing than when you think
we disagree more importantly yes of
course but when you think you're on the
verge of something super cool you're
like pumped about it the day before you
like this in your like oh yeah your ass
kicked and you're like oh man
hello hey Nadia you're on the askgaryvee
show with Ali Wehbe hi oh my gosh this
is crazy it's not that you put a phone
number into the three loves yeah you
know oh my gosh where are you from first
of all yes go ahead
Gary I've been following you for like
seven or eight years since I was before
I even graduated high school and you've
totally changed my mindset in so many
ways and I'm so grateful for that Ali I
am a pretty recent
leave graduated hair stylist so I've
only been working for like a year and a
half amazing dress I Drybar was my first
hair
job ever and so I worked at the
Louisville Kentucky location amazing so
wait wait I am basically yeah Lee and I
are completely responsible for your life
yeah we kind up it's really crazy and
I'm so grateful to have been able to
work at Drybar to begin with because it
really set up ground for me as a stylist
because it gave me comfort and guidance
you my my I didn't really have to have
like that that scary moment of like oh
my gosh I could really screw up
somebody's hair so it's a great
foundation for me as a hair stylist and
I I left about it's probably been like
eight months ago because I wanted to
pursue hair styling as up you know like
a full-service right gig so I want to
color cut that whole thing okay um
anyway I have really just been and
hesitant to put myself out there on
social media which I've done before I've
worked with you know brands and I had a
blog and stuff like that and I kind of
took like a like a break from that but
I'm struggling to get back into it and I
like what's the like what's the true
answer is it because you're starting
from a low point and you don't like the
perception of not having a lot of
followers is it you don't feel great
about you look is it that you know what
the sound in your would like like what's
the real answer let's save time here I
think it comes down to if I put myself
out there and say somebody comes to me
because they liked something that I
posted and that if i disappoint them in
the hair salon that that doesn't let me
tell you from somebody who's doing here
for 20 years I have disappointed people
and I have made a lot of people happy
you will never not disappoint like there
will always be something that if that
doesn't work out I mean it's when I when
I talk to a stylist and sometimes it's
sometimes it's chemistry
you know sometimes and this is something
I tell my stylist all the time like you
can you could do something with
someone's hair that the person next to
you is stylist next you would do the
exact same thing but they might like it
better from them because sometimes it's
just a chemistry thing the way they like
the way you
they way like the way it feels they like
your personality the way you look I mean
speaking going back to judgment it's
like I would ever buy a dress forever or
like person because I would just appease
the person's insecurities I think some
of the reason people go it which is so
true and by the way that's such a great
insight that you have that because the
other thing it's Natalie right Nadia
Nadia the other thing is like just be
confident they're like people can smell
fear on you if you're a hair stylist
like people are expecting you to be
really confident in what you're doing
and and like fake it until you make it
in this industry you just have to come
at it with this like I am you know not
being arrogant but you have to be
confident in what you're doing and and
you know and you have to understand that
like not everyone is gonna love you but
if you come at it with this like you
think you're great you're gonna give
them something great and if and if you
don't you don't and you move on to the
next Noddy I think I'm gonna build on
what Ali said look I think I think
faking confidence is very hard I really
do but let me give you something that I
think could really help you as society
who has an enormous amount of confidence
who's desperately afraid of letting
anyone down I'm gonna say something that
I believe very much and I genuinely
think might work for you you do know
that and the ability to fix a mistake is
the greatest part of being alive it's
how you learn yeah so let me explain I
see a great post I love the last six
things you did on your Instagram I
decide to DM you I come to you I pay you
98 dollars 150 whatever you do your
thing I look in the mirror I go what the
[ __ ] at that moment you are in control
not them mm-hmm you can give her her
money back you can give her three
hairstyles for free in perpetuity like
you can do whatever you want you you're
in control that may not be what
everybody thinks is the right move you
know and I fully understand that but
like most people don't think most things
I do is the right move what Ali thinks
is the right move based on her reaction
what I think this is what's so great
there is no right there's only right for
you for me I
use money right as a way to subsidize
the way I feel and so if I don't feel
good about it
I'll give you great example back to even
the nuance of me and Ali's body language
under this answer if I cut the here Ali
says this is dog [ __ ] and I feel like
Ali's completely out of her mind and
just one of those kind of characters I'm
not giving her another cut or her money
back if Ali says huh this is dog [ __ ]
and I say you know I was worried about
my grandma's health today like I knew I
had another appointment on the back end
and I did rush it a little bit and I
don't feel great my ability to do
something about it
right then and there is real you
shouldn't worry about it because the
reality is you're actually in control
and I agree with that you know but I
think I do think that as a hairstylist
like you you know when you're first
starting out as a hairstylist cuz I've
been in her shoes like it is it's very
jarring and especially like you were
saying about cutting someone's hair
doing something making a permanent
change I remember I was so nervous like
I felt like I was like gonna I was gonna
cut Pete but I when I first got on the
floor when I first started doing hair I
was like nervous I was gonna cut people
I was so [ __ ] scared
but you you have to I understand what
you're saying about not being able to
fake confidence but I think you do have
to dig deep and be like I've got this if
it doesn't work with this woman it
doesn't work it's okay and it is a
learning and it's not gonna always work
I didn't I don't think every haircut I
ever gave has been the greatest haircut
but I learned from every single haircut
I did look I could cover it up with a
great blowout and I think and I think
but I think and I think the other thing
is just understanding you're in control
I mean this weather weather these two
perspectives bring you value or not it's
understanding you're in control like
what like what's gonna happen like
perspective matters to like I don't know
you know scared I am everyday when a 16
year old who's getting like mentally
abused at his home grabs my arm in the
middle of street and asked me what he
should do with his life like it sounds
super scary to cut somebody's ear when
you're cutting their hair you know
what's more scary somebody who's so
bought into you that whatever comes out
of your [ __ ] mouth is how they're
gonna live their life
disproportionally scary situation the
reality is when I know my intent is pure
I'm doing the best I can I try to hedge
that hey here's my point of view kid but
like you know you know and I think you
weren't in control yeah yeah yeah that's
that's really good advice I appreciate
that a lot from both of you all right
good luck thank you so much yeah that's
gonna be fun let's do this all day
listen no joke it's funny you said that
I was thinking the other day like what
you know I put out so much content I do
my thing but this is such a rarity for
me like I run a thousand person company
I'm an operator yeah and I always say
what would happen if I was just Gary Vee
at all times and I said man I would
literally do a morning show called tea
with Gary Vee ironically I'm drinking
tea right the second and I would
literally do this from 7:00 a.m. to
11:00 do I do that every day that's like
my big dream is like having the number
you have dialed is not in that's what I
want to do that's what I kind of I want
my next thing to be a dog show I'm not a
call-in like a TV doctor look I think
you know I sitting it out in the
universe what what what you know back to
you and I having two different kind of
angles yeah not points of view angles
give me while rogoff's getting next say
sir don't descend it yet because I have
a really funny question cuz what I
really enjoyed in that call was a really
important thing which is you know I hear
advice from people that are successful
all the time that would have never
worked for me mm-hmm
right and I give a share and I give my
two cents on things all the time and I
can't necessarily give the right advice
for that person give me give me
something that you thought you heard or
read or advise your parents gave as
entrepreneurs that ended up being very
different than what worked for you was
there anything I feel like my parents
were much more conservative with their
business and the way they went about
things and and their stores were like
you know these like like little old lady
stores and they didn't they didn't spend
a lot of money on the decor and making
it look and feel a certain way there was
more utilitarian the more yeah it really
was and like I remember my might when
Michael was trying to get them to go
switch from like literally cash register
to computer and they were like very
resistant on it they do you know they
were kind of my dad didn't see credit
cards in his liquor store when I first
thought yeah I'm sure and that's how
that's exactly
that's how my parents were and and when
when we told them we were spending you
know half a million dollars in the
build-out of Drybar they were like you
guys ready you're out of your minds like
what are you doing so you know and and
honestly I have to give my brother a lot
of credit because he knew this
award-winning architect Josh Highclere
who helped who's built all our stores
and was like you know he had that
insight even more than I did that like
we have to spend a lot of money to make
it look beautiful so people want to be
there even though we're you know I
wanted to charge $35 and we started
because I wanted this to be an
affordable luxury that women of all
walks of life could do and you know
Michael had the insight to make it look
really beautiful in high-end you struck
supposition and you know that's also
like the beauty of a partnership how
much do you think aspirational
affordability played out your success
time I'm more passionate about this
subject matter you can't have jay-z's
home you can't have jay-z's girl you
can't have jay-z's plane but you can
drink the same well yeah I think that
jay-z has and that's why that works and
that's exactly you know was my thinking
on it was like I want this to be
something that you can do if you're not
a celebrity or can afford to have
somebody coming you're cocky not just
like you know in there's a subset of
obviously there's a lot of them o Jordan
in LA where I live but there's also a
lot of like college students and like
you know working women who don't have
you know can't spend 150 or $300 on a
blowout to go to a wedding or on a date
or whatever it is the price of the
blowout when you launched 3035 and now
forty five and then they go 35 40 45 or
and we have it's been a slow ballad
which you know I knew without goods
reality like rent real life and it's
work you can't go out of business here
oh yeah exactly
hello hey it's Gary Vaynerchuk you're on
with Ali Wehbe on the askgaryvee show
who's this this is Virginia hi Gary
oh my god this was awesome how are you
doing we're doing super well awesome
does it talk to you and you or to Allie
it's it's great to be on a nice meet you
where are you from and what's your
question I'm from York Pennsylvania I
work a full-time day job in an office
also work as pretty much a full-time dog
trainer I train on evenings and weekends
give myself Friday evenings off from dog
training but you know I'm working on
transitioning out really working as hard
as I can to you know build up and up
enough capital so that my husband is
comfortable with me leaving the day job
because it's risky it's more risky to
him that it is to me but it's risky and
I'm finding very recently that I'm
hitting a lot of burnout I hit burnout
like once every couple weeks where I'm
just like [ __ ] exhausted I can't
focus at the day job I don't want to
[ __ ] do anything there I'm doing you
know
dog training stuff on the side and I
just wanted to hear both of your
opinions on dealing with burnout when
you know you can't do anything else but
trudged through it like advice tips that
kind of thing and whether either review
of experience burnout and what you guys
did for yourselves to deal with that
where's the passion in the dog training
right oh yeah yeah you know which one of
you that you just said that because I'm
totally tell well she's also not burned
out she just can't wait to be full-time
dog training yeah I get it okay I mean
here's the thing I feel like everyone
this is like a thing where everyone has
to pay their dues and and it's just rich
I mean [ __ ] I did I'm sure Gary did like
you know you had and I think that like
the way that first of all burnout is
real and yes I've had burnout and by the
way in another life I had a dog-walking
business so I know I am very passionate
about doggies to you and I have two nice
who need some training so if you want to
come out to LA I will book a flight but
but you know I think I mean I think
burnout is real I think I have two
pieces of advice on this like are you
taking care of yourself and are you
doing things that make you feel good and
replenish like for me I think it was
just saying to Gary that I just started
doing Transcendental Meditation or
getting a massage or a manicure or maybe
just like taking a nap or going on a
hike like finding something that like
kind of refuse your soul and to know
this is the second part of it to know
that like the day job is tempor
and it's not gonna always be that way
and you may not be able to see that
right now but you're gonna get to a
point where you're not gonna have to do
the day job because you've been hustling
and hustling and eventually you know the
pendulum is gonna swing towards the
dog-training business and you'll be able
to quit the day job you will as long as
you have the passion and you're working
really hard at it you just have to and I
think the silver lining to get you
through is that you know there is an end
in sight right I also lutely I also
think you have to figure out where the
burnouts coming from so I didn't I
believe that most people get burned out
when they don't feel in control and what
what where I want to go with this
question is the following
I think you're ready to make the move I
think your husband doesn't want you to
and and that's that's the hardest thing
is that sorry I'm outside that's the
hardest thing is that he's very he's
very encouraging for me he wants me to
go full-time it's its financial where
we're kind of in a close financial
straight right now like on other things
like I feel like listen like when I yeah
and we are we definitely are if you ever
have done this and I was just telling a
girl friend of mine who's on who's like
working on a budget like I there's
amazing budget apps and when you know
years ago even now I do this where you
can basically put you give yourself a
set amount of money that you can spend
and you cannot go over it you put
everything you spend every single day in
that and you you basically cut back and
on things that you should make donut you
dinner out your shopping home yeah yeah
we do you should sell it yeah I've
thought about talking to him about that
actually just listen to me and listen to
me real good I don't know whether you
should sell your home or not
but here's what I should tell you and I
believe it more than anything happiness
needs to be the ROI of life not being
able to tell people you own a home
nobody gives a [ __ ] and real estate is
such a good investment
happiness is a better than us I agree
but anyway let's play here yeah example
real estate is a great investment let's
play it out right now the real estate
markets very good she's burnt out every
couple weeks she's not making the move
that she already knows she
do you can feel it through the [ __ ]
weird phone right and one of the reasons
is short-term financial stress I believe
she can sell her home right now in the
height of the market go rent get way
happier happiness leads to effectiveness
she starts this dog walking business
that is successful and what she has to
figure out in the Delta is when the
economy gets softer is the dog walking
business gonna get hurt more than the
appreciation of the real estate and that
becomes a very different kind of
question
but who cares how good your home returns
if you're unhappy
especially when another person is
dictating your decision yeah because
they grant you feels like you're
throwing away money but but but these
are things that we believed in in the
past your parents thought you were an
idiot for $500,000 in esthetics yeah
rent is throwing away money is a 1970s
point of view but now you know it is
paying a mortgage is going towards
something paying but Braga's like that
in the world is your mindset I agree
people want to [ __ ] work out and
spend money on meditation and they don't
want to spend money on their happiness
respect but you should like people were
like hey you need to take a vacation you
escapism the antics the sink but they
don't fix the well yeah she's dying
inside because she's so ready to run
this business and she has a partner in
life that she clearly respects and loves
enough to take into consideration but
she's ready right you're ready right
yeah I have been ready I got completely
you're gonna be more you're gonna be
burning out more often once you make the
mental switch as a human to be ready for
the next thing you can't hold on to the
life here's another little piece of
advice I mean - maybe not sell your
house if you know is like maybe maybe
you go from like the day job that you
hate so much into something that's more
of a day job in the line of work that
you're in go work at you know in LA
there's a place called healthy spot
that's like a dog place I mean go work
at a place that's at least in the arena
of what you love so we went in the
meantime while you're not ready to make
the full-time lead from your day off his
job that you hate
go into a job that you kind of liked it
has to do with dogs it has to like that
can kind of fuel your your passion but
you're not a hundred percent out of a
second income right right I've thought
about that too for sure what's what's
really so like talk to me I'm really
interested in this subject matter I'm
not letting you go just yet like you've
got it I answer some questions for me
your husband's working and contributing
as well
yeah can you rent a room in your house
how many you extra rooms in your house
do you have that you guys don't really
really use honestly none we have a
really small app no I really appreciate
are you marketing your dog training
business like are you how many are you
kiddin cannot get to the next level I
yeah I definitely need to start
investing in more marketing like I
started just by making a profile on
thumbtack calm and I've been like living
off of that but I have my website up and
running I've been getting a lot of
organics which on the website without
even putting any money into Google ads
or Facebook Ads yet so what about
Instagram I have an Instagram page but I
haven't been doing anything with that
yet either I really want you to go ahead
into that dog walking likes pictures of
dogs like that there's nothing that gets
more attention than like really cute
[ __ ] pictures of dogs I mean am i
right
everybody in this appreciate yeah you
can get that's like it's such a like a
slam dunk reading you have a few
pictures of dogs especially if you're
like I can make your dog we're not
waiting to find out what's going on it's
because is it happening out of actual
physical exhaustion or is it more it's
Wednesday and you're going into the next
eight hours and you hate that you're
doing that yes like oh every every
couple weeks I don't get like physically
exhausted I think you and then every
once in a while it's like mental
exhaustion - yeah I mean listen I think
Ali's drilling these practical advices
like I love like I'm a big fan of
getting a different job that pays you
less than the thing you like I just
a bridge no I think it's awesome yeah
I'm just also a pretty big fan of like
selling homes I don't know if I agree
with the selling year I get it I get it
and I think you find something else
because I think you could probably find
something else that you love in the dog
alley world you know what's really
interesting a lot of the Silicon Valley
people that made a ton of money in the
last wave of other houses don't never
owned a home and continue not to I'm
really I think owning a home and going
to college in 25 to 40 years is gonna
look more like women should stay home
and raise families did 30 years ago 50
years ago I'm not kidding really I
really do why because because I think
the the practicality around them was
more realistic for the world we lived in
in the past but if you own a home you're
putting money towards something that you
own if you're renting something you're
putting money that you toward something
that you don't get back but when you
take into account people not knowing how
to put down deposits which may be the
answer to this question right you have
to do it smart and you have to yeah
that's not what actually manifests right
and so like to me when you take three
hundred thousand or fifty thousand or
ten thousand dollars out of your account
and you add up mortgage you know to me
for what like you know like for what
like what like okay so you have an asset
so you're making an assumption that the
appreciation of that is going to turn
into something that you what you sell
and then move to Florida like I think
there's you know they don't think it has
to be a huge gain you know if you can if
you can gain you know 50 grand or a
hundred grand or whatever it is from the
buying from selling your house to
upgrading a little bit that 50 grand or
100 grand worth living another four and
a half years old in an unhappy state I
think there's other things she can be
doing should not be answering questions
that I don't like she has no extra rooms
job she hasn't given us a whole lot of
other things and she's got the support
of her husband he wants her to just
pursue this full-time I think there's a
way how how well is the dog business
doing uh fairly well I I'm pretty much
I'm I'm booked out for the next two
weeks with appointments I have consoles
and consoles coming in let me ask you a
question without being delirious and
your best guess how much do you think
you can make
if you went full-time just your best
guess be relatively conservative like
don't be emotionally excited like try to
really give me an answer here like like
what do you think guaranteed I could
make as much as I'm making it the day
job probably another 20 grand more than
that so like 60 right now what's
happening now what's happening with you
is the debate that Ali and I are having
in a great way which is the thing that
drives me like you cannot imagine which
is perception versus reality yeah just
do it you are taking on your husband's
lack of interest in risk and making it
your own in a world where if you do not
quit your job tomorrow's quit you John
pissed
yes quit your job you will have a you
have such a short amount of downtime
prepare for that time get ready to make
sure you guys don't spend any money that
you absolutely don't have to spend even
if it takes you I think maybe not
tomorrow
if you takes you a month to get your
like act your ducks in a row so you can
then say okay I'm gonna quit I'm gonna
give myself a month to build on my
business and then you're done you just
want to do it you mean the business that
pays you as much as the [ __ ] job you
have it that you that makes you have
mental burnout this is like this is like
entrepreneurialship 101 like this is the
problem honestly and I don't know if you
agree Gary that most entrepreneurs have
they are so afraid to leave their jobs
and to pursue their passion usually
because of money which is why you know
it's like either now maybe you're you're
so far gone that you're so unhappy but
to all entrepreneurs out there listening
if you have if you have intent and hope
to eventually start your own business
start putting money aside in a secret
account that you cannot touch now so
once you're really ready to pursue that
you have a cushion I feel like so many
people I talk to you don't have the the
they're not set up to start their
business and that's the point where
they're burnt down I answer is to raise
capital not get yourself to position or
if there's you know you're your mate or
parents or somebody who can give you
that like buffer that cushion so then
you can go and do it you know you have
to just get yourself prepared to it
sometimes that takes a year but
remaining
Virginia who's in your world saying jump
and who's in your world saying don't
jump
my husband saying jump in a little while
how long does he do saying that not that
long because I haven't really I haven't
really been gung-ho about going
full-time like I've been saying Oh next
year I'll do it like last year I was
saying next year's the year and now that
I'm here I'm like okay by the end of the
summer and he's going duh if you're
ready then okay by the end of the summer
listen life is short my friend like you
know it's like life is too short to be
like doing something that you're not
happy and like you know it's like a
colles tune has changed because you gave
her because what I love about Ally and
gathering here I want her to sell her
house that's fine and I respect and I'll
tell you why you don't want her to sell
her house because your filter is proper
it's very practical yeah I'll everything
that's come out of your mouth has been
so disproportionate practical the only
difference between you and I on this
issue is I have a perspective today that
believes selling a home is a practical
behavior yeah and you don't that's okay
yeah but everything you've been saying
is practical the recent alleys changing
or tuned to go now and and life is short
is you've given her the data and the
information to know this transition is
practical I've got new screen by the way
this is by doing this for a long time
you're going to do 25 to 50 percent
better than you think yeah just so you
know real quick when you call back in a
year you're gonna make fifty percent
more than your job because of everything
I've heard yours by the way I think you
called in today because you wanted a
solution to tell you what to do it
hundred percent and we're telling you to
do it pursue your dream your husband on
the phone yeah three way he's been a
really big board meeting actually I
don't think you can get on the phone
what's his name I want
you me and Jake on a phone in the next
24 hours I want you to email Gary at
vaynermedia calm I want me you and Janet
on Mystica huh Allie you can be part of
it for we call Tommy four-way call that
new FaceTime group [ __ ] and I want to
tell like there listen to me and listen
to me good
you need to move fast I mean the world
can end next week and like like there's
no doubt that this is what you should be
doing yeah there really isn't and you by
the way the reason you've been recently
burnt out more because you're ready
you switched you switch yeah you chew
your swing went off and now it's all
terrible it's why in fourth grade like
we Daniel anymore
I switched in 4th grade in 4th grade I
switched from school is the way out
school is good school will help me - oh
[ __ ] school will not help me school is
not the way out and I switched
dramatically earlier than most people
but this is when you switch when you're
in a relationship one week earlier
you're in love we're gonna get married
life is amazing and then something
happens and you switch and then three
months later people break up like this
is you for what you know that your
switch switched yeah I know you're
unhappy and by the way you're gonna get
so you're gonna get systematically more
unhappy yep mmhmm yep there's only one
way to go from here Virginia you
switched Virginia do it alright thank
you guys so much I appreciate it so much
Gary and Allie I really do
good luck good luck and thank jeanja
don't take the high of this 17 minute 33
percent hold on to it and like you need
to hold like this is you need this
tonight when you talk to Jake you need
this tomorrow you need this you need
this at do not do what everybody does
what you're hyped is [ __ ] now and your
heads like yep monday or a month from
now and like the reason I want you to go
tomorrow and not 30 days from now is I'm
worried about the vulnerability of 30
days from now actually becomes September
the day after Labor Day which then
actually becomes Christmas when then
then something reader happens and all of
a sudden it because and [ __ ] [ __ ]
Virginia yeah
[ __ ] Virginia and meanwhile I asked
if I get cursive hell yeah like [ __ ]
quit tomorrow yeah go I'm with you and
if you quit tomorrow I'll make you
promise if you quit tomorrow I will
personally never do this I will
personally heavily shout out your
business on social to get you 50 clients
you would have never had I will to an
ally will too
but you can go Surratt quit tomorrow and
you have to prove it you're so intense
you enter to sell her house and quit her
job I do you know what you can come live
with Gary - you sure can cuz I'm [ __ ]
about happiness here yeah you guys Rock
thank you so much what's gonna happen
tomorrow she's gonna quit her job and
sell her house it's [ __ ] quitting man
Virginia are you are you gonna quit
tomorrow yeah are you sure I am no for
real for real
don't [ __ ] with me cuz my let's get
crazy hurry Oh Gary cuz you're ready
right I am you quit six weeks ago 13
weeks ago now you're just going through
negative emotions yeah I am
I know all right I love you and this is
this is so fun good luck we'll listen
don't like say too much because you know
we're gonna get bombarded by TV
producers and being like you too we
should have a show all right I gotta get
you out of here yeah thank you
yes question of the day you get to ask
it every time I guess sound here they
get to ask the question of the day what
now be selfish or curious here you're
gonna get a lot of answers on social so
what question do you want to ask the
masses whether you want to be very
directly to your business something
macro wherever you want to go this is
your your opportunity but the question
of day for mailing what's at your age
demo'd you know yeah of course you know
it's kind of like so it's like very
heavy 17 to 35 year old male then male
yeah well I never get mailed em about a
65% okay then 35% is like 27 - 49
year-old female okay um I you know what
I I knew about this question so I was
thinking about it all day I'm kind of
curious like what in like today's
society like what is the most like with
social media and everything is what is
he
most important what do people care what
do you care about the most in the world
like you know is it like your family's
is it your job like I'm just so curious
like what is driving people today um and
before we go off the air so a girl in my
office her name is Stacy Levine she's
she's my sweet Stacy she's my social
media like I don't know what her actual
title is [ __ ] Stacy I love you she's
like so near and dear to my heart she's
obsessed with you but I told her that I
would give you her a shout-out and you
would give her a shout-out they see I
loved were she in LA he's in yeah she's
in California I hope I get to meet you
Stacy thank you so much for the love
thanks for watching thank you for having
me this is so so fun you guys are
awesome this is so cool you keep asking
questions we'll keep answering them
on this episode Rockstar entrepreneur
Alli Webb stops by awesome